huit jours dont nous avions de souvenir
d'un jeune premier c'est un comédien
affirme confirmés qui nous revient
comment est-ce que cette évolution s'est
produite eh bien je crois que
en observant en vivant à hollywood j'ai
vécu beaucoup seul avec ma femme je
crois que j'ai eu le temps de réfléchir
olivo est une ville très curieuse avec
certes un certain tempérament
l'influencé mauvaise je crois j'espère
en tout cas que pour moi elle a été
bonne parce que je me suis remis fait
entre les gones je n'ai pas accepté
hollywood veut j'aime bien y vivre
j'aime bien surtout y travailler mais
non font ça n'est pas pour moi
vous venez de dire que l'atmosphère des
ludes est mauvaise
qu'entendez-vous exactement par cela et
les pas mauvaise elle est mauvaise au
point sur le plan du du comédien le
comédien devient un peu un
fonctionnaire le comédien sous contrat
il est à l'affût de la sécurité des deux
l'affût du contrat de longue durée ce
qui m'avait pour le développement d'un
acteur moi je suis resté sous contrat
s'étend avec des pics thermiques et
c'est pendant ces sept ans que je me
suis rendu compte que ça n'était pas
possible je n'étais pas la vie d'un
acteur la vie d'un acteur n'est pas le
confort la sécurité c'est le contraire
c'est la découverte des choses nouvelles
c'est l'insécurité c'est la recherche il
n'en demeure pas moins que cette
recherche n'exclut pas chez le comédien
ni le confort ni la sécurité non non
bien sûr mais je crois que
ont créé mieux on fait mieux mon métier
et tout métier toutes professions
artistiques dans l'empêchement et dans
la fièvre dans l'inquiétude que dans la
douceur et la
certitude et la quiétude cette maturité
vous l'avez donc trouver dans cette
atmosphère qui au départ n'était pas
favorable à l'éclosion d'un comédien
tels que vous l'entendez mais comment
expliquez vous alors qu'hollywood
produisent tout de même des
chefs-d'oeuvre mai les bons films faits
à hollywood sont le résultat de
personnalités isolées qui
n'appartiennent pas au système
un homme comme délit wild vous voyez
moelle ou et à kazan
sont en deçà du système hollywoodien
quand ils font un film c'est eux qui le
font c'est leur personnalité qui est sur
l'écran ça n'est pas fabriqué par le
système comprenait ce sont évidemment
des films fait hollywood mais pas dans
la mentalité